[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
allez tout le monde nouvelle année
nouveaux épisodes alors on reprend
tranquillement par un petit hors série
alors dieu pour revenir sur le pré
stentor ciel on m'avait demandé
plusieurs fois en message privé pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai pas parlé de tel dessin
animé ou de tel autre scène j'ai même
pas eu le temps de tout lire
pour les dessins animés trith j'aurais
pu vous parler aussi par exemple du bois
de katsuni d'autres séries ou au fil des
épisodes on suit la vie de plusieurs
animaux de la forêt dans leur nature et
qui les amène par exemple par les
différents
j'aurais pu aussi vous parler plus
longuement de dragon ball z
oui encore je sais mais bon c'est en
fait d'un passage en particulier ça a
été les cinq minutes les plus longues de
ma vie et de la vôtre il n'arrête jamais
[Musique]
dans cinq minutes est exactement une
nouvelle exposition progression accuse
alors encore et la planète sera plus
qu'un tas de 30
alors on y est là dans cinq minutes
le dénouement final
tu as compris il ne te reste plus que
deux minutes à lire presse admira droit
bon ok à peu près cinq minutes
alors tu as droit à quelques minutes de
répit
cinq minutes exactement temps mais on
est repassé à cinq minutes des
prolongations ou quoi
tu paries bien sûr deux arrêtés par les
arrêter de vous fixer comme ça et battez
vous réserve d'énergie torture mais là
tout pour rendre fou ça la vraie joie
qui utilisent tous adorent vivre ça
lorsque franchir tortue géniale imprégné
du combat pendant ce temps là bas mais
[ __ ] bien sûr par les dragons souvent
me demande pourquoi j'aime pas dragon
ball gt
ben c'est simple pour ceux qui n'ont
jamais regardé je résume dragon ball gt
c'est un peu comme si un virus était
passé sur l'univers de dbz avait
transformé tout le monde touchera
appelle donc sangoku est redevenue
enfant et parent dans l'espace pour
chercher des dragon ball parce que sinon
la planète explose me demandez pas
pourquoi je suis même pas sûr que les
scénaristes le savaient eux mêmes et
donc sont beaucoup trop de saipan
partout dans l'espace pour les retrouver
tout à fait remis de monter dans la
navette
jean numéro eux de ne pas aimer dragon
ball gt végéta avec une moustache
peu importe la raison ça ça n'est pas
tolérable
voilà comment qu'ils ont changé en cours
de route raison numéro 2 trucks est
devenue une [ __ ] alors d'abord trois
adultes et pour plusieurs raisons un des
personnages préférés des gens dans
l'univers de dbz
il est jeune il est cool il est sympa
mais il a aussi un côté sombre qui rend
le personnage intéressant trucks en
dragon ball gt est une vieille banane
volée puissante qui s'habille comme un
scout et qui nous démontre dans chaque
épisode son inutilité
d'ailleurs au passage je le soupçonne
d'avoir aussi quelques vices cachés en
voudrait une chambre s'il vous plaît
n'ai aucun problème monsieur oui donnez
moi une seule chambre pour moi et ses
deux jeunes enfants s'il vous plaît
sérieusement je vous jure il ya des
scènes qui m'ont donné envie de hurler à
mon dieu je suis bloqués sous des
rochers
si ça nous avait avril de transformer en
un jour de guerriers mais un truc
davantage super un des oui c'est vrai
raison numéro trois dans tous les
dessins animés on a pris un peu
l'habitude d'intégrer un personnage
mascotte un vous savez le truc un peu
inutile mais qui est sympathique et
linon ses personnages les minions dit
sympathique il est juste voilà ça c'est
dit comme ça allait la suite cette
semaine en fait j'avais envie de vous
parler d'un thème en particulier dans
mes tests de jeux vidéo j'ai souvent
parlé de deux jeux qui étaient adaptés
de films ou de dessins animés mais l'
inverse existe aussi il ya eu des
dessins animés ou des films qui ont été
adaptés de jeux
évidemment les plus évidents ce sont les
dessins animés sur mario et sonic n'y en
a eu plusieurs et pour les mario il ya
eu mario bros 3 super mario world
magnifique danse de fin générique
d'ailleurs ensuite pour les sonic le
plus connu en france le tout premier
d'ailleurs ici comme dans beaucoup de
dessins animés de cette époque qui se
terminait toujours sur une leçon de
morale
[Musique]
on est cerné sonic appelant les secours
d'urgence
nommons view thèse il n'y a rien de
grave on peut régler ça tout seul ben
oui les enfants pas la peine envers des
gens quand trois personnes veulent vous
tabasser et débrouillez vous tout seul
un peu enfin d'air de l'exemple de jeux
vidéo en d'opter en dessin animé le plus
évident ça serait évidemment pokémon et
mais je veux dire je ne peux pas en
parler je suis désolé à cette série est
hyper cruel quand il pense là on parle
quand même d'aller capturer des pauvres
animaux inoffensifs dans la forêt de les
tabasser jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient assez
faibles pour les enfermer dans des
boules toute leur vie et de leur faire
sentir seulement pour combattre dans des
arènes
heureusement les pokémon peuvent pas
parler comme en face à lens cure au
centre
collection d'un petit quelque chose
espèce de sa loge et fo mise dans la
bouche avant de te reconnais struggle il
est heureux dans la nature j'avais une
bonne vingtaine de familles terrorisées
mari je te déteste ça et puis enfin sans
déconner mais quand ils pensent les
parents c'est des [ __ ]
d'irresponsables enfin je veux dire
essayer de transposer ça en vrai maman
j'ai dix ans mais ça pour tonelico les
parties à faire du braconnage espère
convaincre des pitbulls dans des cafés
soir je vais terminer soir j'étais quand
même content share qui va de ville en
ville avec ses chiens
d'accord mais surtout n'oublie pas de
rencontrer des inconnus passons notre
dessin animé peu connue en france mais
qui est adapté d'un jeu vidéo qui lui
est extrêmement connue je parle de
legend of zelda connu sous le nom de
princesse zelda en france alors bon
c'est devenu introuvable en france et
donc je m'excuse par avance
faut dire que dans la version française
les voix des personnages changer
tellement que des fois ça même épisode
il avait deux voies différentes
donc prenons le jeu le héros nine qui
doit être brave quoi je intrépide et
digne de sauver la princesse zelda qui
ré les sens et faire des trucs de
princesse jean chey pas être faible et
fragile regarder par la fenêtre de son
château d'un air mélancolique vous
chanter des chansons devant la pleine
lune voilà c'est bien la danse dessin
animé c'est les verts ce link est un
vieux pervers en gros il passe son temps
à se plaindre de sa vie au château mais
reste là pour une seule raison dans tout
le monde tous les épisodes il va essayer
de se farcir zelda en la harcelant
toutes les deux minutes pour la brasse
et moi qui - qui inquiète comment alors
oui d'accord le premier on a tous
étaient frustrés d'anjouan des jeux
zelda ne pas voir link et zelda
s'embrasser à la fin voilà mais là il ya
quand même peut-être exagération enfin
là ça tourne carrément harcèlement
sexuel il tente de s'introduire dans sa
chambre la nuit pour marcher parfois
plus il son père qui le regarde il lui
saute dessus ils abattent au réveil
depuis sa jambe et s'est embrouillé axa
comme des formes silhouette attaques la
semaine
[Musique]
ce qui met sérieusement c'est comme ça
que vous imaginez lille vous mêmes c'est
comme ça que vous imaginiez une série
sur l'univers de zelda
franchement on dire american pie ou un
de ses films pour ados ou demande me
coucher ensemble spring la fée veut se
taper link gagnent on veut se taper
zelda mêmes alsace est aussi une
allumeuse
puis 9 vous croyez que c'est un beau
message pour les gamins qui regardent
ils enfoncent si vous voulez embrassé
une fille et qu'elle veut pas de vous
découragez pas pourquoi mais par exemple
la harcelait tout cela j'aurais où vient
rentrée la nuit dans sa chambre par
effraction pendant qu'elle dort le
scénario s'est pas vraiment mieux
gagnante qui vole la triforce tous les
deux jours en passant par là même [ __ ]
de fenêtres qui reste toujours ouverte
et personne n'a l'idée de la fermer
franchement cette série ne respecte rien
ni le caractère des personnages ni les
combats ça vous fait penser à celle d'at
grave donc
[Musique]
là une épée nom de dieu sap avait
annoncé la nasa sans doute un desk zelda
appris à tirer des boules d'énergie
bon allez passons notre jeu vidéo qui a
été adapté en avait street fighter
bon je vais pas vous parler du film pour
pas devenir vulgaire à la place je vais
plutôt vous parler de la série animé
sorti en 95 sous le nom de street
fighter 2 v qui est censé raconter la
genèse de ryu qui part à contrer son ami
kane et qui oui bon ça je sais je sais
très bien à quoi vous pensez je refuse
de faire c'est le blog donc tout au fil
des premiers épisodes un ryu et ken
parts voyager ensemble à travers le
monde et rencontreront ensuite en chemin
chez lui nos trois amis ont su de ville
en ville comme en exemple à hong kong en
chine en amérique ici feront les
magasins ils labourent ont des champs
puis ils iront voir des corridas et non
c'est vrai que c'est sympa de voir ken
ryu et oni se promener à travers tous
les pays du monde pour aider les gens à
résoudre leurs problèmes personnels mais
il ya un petit truc qui me gêne je
n'arrive pas exactement à définir ce que
c'est cet essai ça y est je sais on s'en
fout en fait voilà c'est ça ouais enfin
bref un jour où sean lee et qu'elle se
promenait dans un magasin pour s'acheter
un sac à main riou lui va par hasard
tombé sur un vieux chinois qui va lui
apprendre la ténue hadôken moi j'ai
découvert l'existence des meilleurs de
pégase après un entraînement en grèce
qui m'a conduit aux frontières de mon
esprit pour ouvrir la puissance de mon
cosmo dresser un vieux qui me l'a appris
dans un super u ils décideront ensuite
d'aller jusqu'en même pour la prendre
auprès de dhalsim qui maîtrise cette opa
qui s est trouvé seul système
je savais que vous finiriez par venir me
voir mes coups tout moment pouviez-vous
le savoir parce que je vous ai vus
arriver mais pourquoi vous êtes aveugle
avec vos yeux révulsés
non c'est juste parce que ça me donne
l'air cool et parce que sinon je louche
et sinon pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit
apprendre une technique chinoise
millénaire avec un vieux prêtre indien
loi d'okun d'ailleurs parlons-en
pour rappel la dokken c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le coup le plus connu de street
fighter il al'avantage d'être facile à
faire et rapide et dans cette série ryu
grâce à l'aide de dhalsim apprend
finalement la technique du ados mais
qu'est ce qu'il fout je lui ai jamais
demandé à leon les bras
alors là pour préciser je tiens à dire
que j'ai rien touché c'est la vraie
durée du hadôken mais ils ont
heureusement que ça dure pas longtemps
[Musique]
pourtant c'est pas difficile de faire
battre diagonale droite et punch
en accélérant jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au
moment où il réussit enfin concentrer le
flux énergétiques qui lui permet de
dégager la puissance nécessaire pour
maîtriser la tête et pendant ce temps là
le terrible général bison qu'on plante
dans l'ombre aussi transforme toi rend
méchant de faire animer et suffit de
quelques éclairs et de musique
dramatique
[Musique]
avant que les trois héros se font
capturer par bison qui les amène sur sa
base secrète galilée jean reno partent à
leur recherche et qui donnait n'était
pas un de ses deux garçons par hasard
nous regardez bien ces trucs là j'avais
dit que je ferais pas cette blague
maintenant si vous êtes amené à regarder
cette série ou si vous l'avez déjà vu il
ya quelque chose qui a dû vous marquez
c'est l'utilisation totalement abusive
de flashbacks savons mais c'est
impossible de suivre une histoire plus
de cinq minutes sans avoir eu un flash
back
j'ai rien contre les plages bac cela
permet de rappeler l'histoire mais est
ce que c'est vraiment utile de mettre
des plages bon pour montrer ce qui s'est
passé il ya dix minutes quoi
enfin les gens qui regardent sont pas
des poissons rouges quand même
sérieusement imaginer si moi je faisais
pareil pendant mes terres salut tout le
monde cette semaine je vais tester un
nouveau jeu du chat megadrive qu'ils
apprennent je vais tester un nouveau jeu
[Musique]
un nouveau jeu sur megadrive
cette semaine je vais tester c'est même
pas vrai plus par semaine je vais tester
[Musique]
donc on arrive ainsi au dernier épisode
où ken ryu et bisons se retrouvent pour
un combat final tout sera enfin expliqué
ah ça c'est le moment que je préfère
attention c'est l'heure des explications
scientifiques de [ __ ] animations je
ressens la même sensation que j'avais
eue dans cette grotte ornée maintenant
que tu le dit effectivement ça me
revient c'était pareil
et tu crois qu'on est dans le phénomène
virtuel d'illusions bise en cet endroit
n'est pas le fruit d'une illusion
vous êtes dans la dimension au toutes
les formes d'énergie trouvent leur
source
pardon en d'autres termes vous pouvez
aussi appeler cette dimension les tests
nous la font ceci dit m
une toux de cette activité temporaire a
tancé pendant les chevaliers du zodiaque
ça normalement
et enfin passons au jeu qui a eu des
adaptations absolument énorme je parle
de mortal kombat street fighter la
franchise a été adapté en dessin animé
en fils et en série aux alentours de 95
une génération
alors que la paix les bons films sont
enfin revenus sur terre après la fin du
premier opus les portes de l'outremonde
se rouvre et de nouveau les bioman de
l'enfer reviennent à la vie cité par un
haut cadre
[Musique]
shao kahn l'empereur d'autres mondes
oui non mais je comprends assez chiant
de devoir marcher après une séquence de
combat aussi mal fait inutile des ninjas
snooze ecstasy se jette donc à l'assaut
de nos héros mais heureusement grâce à
rieden ils réussissent à s'enfuir de ce
temple thaïlandais en prenant un tunnel
qui ressort directement à hawaï d'accord
raquin revenir sur ses pas et tourné là
où je te les indiqué noter la petite
explication de rayonne pour faire croire
que tout seul parfaitement volumes dans
le complexe scientifique sonia
retrouvent à leur jaxx mais
malheureusement cyrax qui lui aussi
avait lu le scénario du film se retrouve
ici purement par hasard
s'engage alors un terrible combat en
premier plan seulement 1 parce qu en
arrière plan et font semblant plan
d'arrière plan qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après ce terrible combat les deux se
retrouvent en plein désert et là oh mon
dieu oh mon dieu de la techno qui
commence vite sonia au plus tôt un
méchant barre des 2 minutes et wimille
et nains autres personnages de mortal
kombat qui passe est purement par hasard
saute sur sonya blade s'en suit ensuite
un combat dans la boue mais ensuite il
ya dragons qui sort d'une statue et puis
ensuite jax tabasse le dragon et puis le
caméraman aussi
et ça les jeux c'est ce qu'ont ils ont
écrit ce film j'ai l'impression qu'ils
ont foutu tous les noms des personnages
dans une boîte à chaussures
ils ont tiré au hasard lors des combats
quoi il faut qu'on s'assoit et qu'on
l'attend le mans qui se retrouvent dans
par hasard au même endroit avec graydon
qui entrera en fait couper les cheveux
reading nouveau look après tout c'est
pas parce que c'est la fin du mot qu'il
faut pas prendre soin de son look elle
ce film franchement c'est des grands
moments de rigolade c'est terminé pauvre
xio vous êtes tombés dans le piège et ce
fut je suis une mauvaise actrice je
voulais travailler maintenant vous allez
me fixer plutôt comme des idiots parce
que je m'enfuis va regarder ça merde
comment personne peut voir s'enfuir la
passe devant tout le monde attend on a
fait cinq minutes qu'il n'y a pas eu de
combats les gens commencent à réfléchir
sur ce qu'est ce que vous foutez vous et
de la techno
[Musique]
m
bref accélérons un peu les divers
événements jusqu'au combat final mais
seulement après que tout le monde ait
fait ces tête de méchant hein ah la
belle fête à tête de méchoui or ça c'est
mes chances alors je vous dirais bien
que le combat final est un splendide
duel entre le héros et shao kahn mais
non se sont sentis obligés rajouter des
mômes et effets spéciaux donc à la place
on a va
[Musique]
or rigolez pas c'est une boîte française
qui a fait les effets spéciaux
bref après cette baston le monde est
sauvé par un filtre photoshop et des
images des clercs et crustacés et tout
redevient normal c'est génial ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'en fait ce final il
est pas si mauvais si on le compare avec
le final d'une autre oeuvre de mortal
kombat mortal kombat conquest la série
télé donc on prend les mêmes raiden et
son disciple kong là où ainsi que ses
amis qui vont se battre contre celui qui
veut conquérir le monde
shao kahn je suis régalé
le dieu du tonnerre
moi je suis dans l'hérault où nous mais
là si je vous parle de cette série en
fait c'est pas pour vous parler des 12
épisodes intrigue inutiles ou de la
tentative désespérée de regagner de
l'audience en transformant mortal kombat
conquest en série porno dans le dernier
épisode mais tu as année un ami avec toi
[Musique]
d'aller non non et c'est pas important
que toute la scène
contentez-vous de fixer bêtement la
poitrine pour des passagers d'un ferry
dans cette série
ce qui est terrible par don dans cette
série c'est la manière dont elle se fit
il faut dire pendant que ray d'un échec
au calme se retrouvent face à face une
fois encore pour s'affronter les trois
personnages principaux dont le héros de
la série se font en cercle et à
l'extérieur par des notes culte là on
sent la tension qui monte là on sent
qu'un terrible combat qui se prépare le
combat final de la série où les trois
héros de mortal kombat vont se battre
malgré le surnombre évident pour leur
vie mais aussi pour la justice et pour
quelque chose
ok alors passons à l'autre combat ce
combat terrible entre chaque année red
hot entre les deux frères ennemis
destiné à se battre dans un probable pic
reizen le dieu du tonnerre qui va devoir
affronter shao kahn jusqu'à ce que mort
s'ensuive et que le bien triomphe enfin
retourner dans notre monde
où jusqu'à ce qu'il ait plus de batterie
au ti et la série finit comme ça c'est
pas une blague c'est le dernier épisode
shao kahn a gagné un jeu du corps tous
les héros sont morts et rennes n'a plus
de piles et la série finit mal en gros
si tu as regardé la série ben tu la
regardes est pour rien samu sinon mais
c'est juste honteux mais mais vous
imaginez ça mais c'est une [ __ ] de
techniques de finhan qui prouve que les
gens qui faisait cette série n'avait
absolument aucune idée plus qu'une
imagination sur la manière de conclure
leur série et qui est absolument sa roue
[Musique]